All right.
>> Okay, so here's the idea.
So just close your eyes in a minute,
well don't close your eyes,
because I'm going to show you this but
imagine,
>> [LAUGH]
>> Imagine you have cloud of data.
>> All right.
>> Got it?
>> I do.
>> And
let's say some of it's labeled minus.
>> Mm-hm.
>> In fact the vast majority is labeled
minus, and just a few are labeled plus.
Well if we do it as we've done before
as requiring learning algorithms do,
we were basically going to say all of
them were negative
>> Okay, as you've said.
>> So,
here's what were going to do instead.
We're going to build a learner,
that's going to label about half of
them negative and half of them positive.
>> I can make one of those.
>> But,
it's going to have another property.
>> Doh!
>> So you take that cloud that I had.
>> Okay.
>> And half of them are negative,
let's say the negative ones come down
here, and the positive ones go this way.
Now, here's the thing.
All the negative ones are actually
true negatives, okay?
>> I see.
>> The problem was we'll
include all the positives, but
also some of the negatives.
So I'll have no false negatives,
and I'll have many false positives.
>> So in the causing trouble in
the airport example, you would.
Like half the people you would say
these people are not a threat, and
you'd just be right on those.
>> Yes.
>> But the other half you might say
these could be a threat-
>> Or
even say that they are a threat and
you'll be wrong for most of them, but
all the ones who are threats
will survive that filter.
>> I see.
>> So now, that I've got the cloud,
and it's over here, and
I've got mostly negatives,
and a few positives.
I keep doing the same thing.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So I shove the negatives off, and
I'm never wrong, and shove the
positives, and it goes on and on and on.
>> It sort of vaguely
reminds me of boosting.
>> It does, and in fact, the way that
they did this in the original paper is
they did boosting over
very simple learners.
But what's interesting here,
there's a couple of points.
One is, I started out with this
big cloud, mostly negatives and
a few positives.
I kept cutting in half, and
by the time I got over here, I have a
much smaller set, and now it's balanced.
So now half of them are negative,
and half of them are positive.
>> because we keep separating
the chaff from the wheat.
>> Right, yeah, let's go with that.
And so
the year with the sort of small set, and
now I can apply my learner here, with
the sort of 50/50 split let's say, and
I actually do a pretty good job.
Now there's two things that
are worth pointing out here.
>> Okay.
>> Well, there's a zero thing, which is-
>> It's like you haven't pointed out
anything so far.
>> I'm pointing everywhere.
>> Yeah.
>> Now, here's the other thing,
here's the cool thing.
Notice that, as I go from this data
over here to this smaller, and smaller.
If I'm right, and
I get about half the data surviving
the filter, then I can actually put.
Twice as much learning
energy in each level.
>> I'm pretty sure we didn't
study learning energy.
>> Well I'm thinking
computational effort, right?
>> All right.
I see, to make it faster.
>> Right.
So, if I keep going down my hill-
>> Because the expected amount
of computation is going to be quite
small, because most people come in and
they get filtered in the first level.
>> Right.
>> It's like a log thing.
>> Yeah, so the size of the data that
I'm looking at is going down [CROSSTALK]
>> But that means is that if I, or
by a factor of two.
Which means that,
if I can put in a factor of two
more of computational effort.
>> I see.
>> And big O, it's going to be the same.
>> Neat.
>> So.
I can basically do something stupid,
less stupid, and
by the time it gets in I can do
something actually rather sophisticated.
Which I couldn't apply over here,
because it would take too
much computational effort.
>> I see, again, the expected
cost would be tremendous, but
here the change in expected cost is very
small, because very little of the data
actually makes it all the way
through that pipeline.
>> Right, so that's point one.
Point two is,
I now have this series of learner.
And over here I've got a nice learner,
that does a nice job of
separating everything out.
But you'll notice that
if I took that learner.
You might say,
well let's just take this learner, and
I can just apply it from
the very beginning.
I mean, after all,
now that I've learned the learner,
it's not computationally painful,
I can, usually I can [CROSSTALK]
>> I see because the classifier is fast,
[CROSSTALK] the learning process was,
okay?
And that's really good,
except it will do terribly, because why?
>> It has a different distribution data.
>> It has a different distribution.
It learned on this distribution,
not this distribution.
>> Got it.
>> So you still have to do this
cascade of learners.
That's why it's called cascade learners.
>> I thought it was
because like detergent.
>> It is like detergent, it scrubs out.
I don't know enough about the Cascade
commercials to make a terrible
pun here, but.
>> All right,,
let's substitute the terrible pun here.
>> Leaves drops the spot, right,
that's the whole [CROSSTALK]
>> Yeah.
>> So all the spotting
stuff comes over here, and
you think of those that drops the spot
and you get spotting [INAUDIBLE].
>> [LAUGH]
>> I'm glad we went through that effort.
Anyway, so this sort of casting
learning thing works really well, and
it gets you to this nice little place
where you've got this [INAUDIBLE].
>> Good.
>> And there's all
kinds of things out there like that
in the supervised learning world.
>> Can you name something that's
had an impact on I don't know,
things that people have experience with?
>> What do you mean?
>> My understanding is that
they use some version of this,
in hand held cameras, when they actually
put a little box around your face.
>> I didn't realize that.
Although it makes sense,
because the original work in
fact was in exactly that space.
>> Yeah.
>> It was sort of doing face
finding-
>> Finding a face.
Yeah.
>> Where they used very
simple kind of pixel based-
>> because most regions of an image
don't have a face in them.
>> Right.
>> Yeah.
Finding a face.
>> Well it depends on
the image that you have.
I'm with you.
Okay, so any way there are tons of
things like that you should explore, and
hopefully you are now prepared
to not just explore them, but
to even understand them.
>> Cool.
>> So that's.
>> Nice.